welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and stranger things for released a
trailer with a huge reveal that no one
thought was possible after season 3
david harbors fur can be cut by mortal
shears last season's post-credits scene
hinted that the Russians had an American
in captivity in a facility where they
also have a demagogue in or the
demagogue it has them it's kind of a who
reviewed whose situation they're that
American is now confirmed to be hopper
who somehow survived the explosion under
the star court mall now the mystery is
how was he alive and how did he end up
in Russia and how the hell do both these
questions also apply to the demo organ
tis has really been the season here at
new rock stars for making eight to nine
minute mountains out of 45 second mole
hills but that's how I does I rewatched
this puppy like 80 times and found a
hawk in town when parties work the
details I'm gonna break them all down
and spoiler warning against any of these
theories and it being too right and they
ruin your life it happens lives have
been ruined here we go
okay we find ourselves what looks to be
a Russian prison camp in some remote
frozen wooded area of Siberia the
Russians would have used forced labor
like this to build railroad tracks look
closely you can see guards shoving
prisoners screaming at other prisoners
who kneel and exhaustion dogs barking
and Russian probably it's a nightmare
now I would argue that winter is the
worst time to be building train tracks
you know with the ground frozen and all
but you know it's free labor and fly to
Vostok needs its vodka by Christmas that
said it's also possible that the
facility Hopper was in needs to be able
to make large cargo shipments in and out
of it that facility had what looked like
airplane hangars you know for access by
air but I couldn't make out any train
lines for ground access and heavier
cargo and if that facility wanted this
ship out bio weapons like Dimmick organs
trains might be a safer way to do it the
campaign we are here in here is the
Russian war anthem the Red Army is the
strongest also known as White Army Black
Baron the song dates back to the Russian
Civil War when Pyotr Wrangel
nicknamed the black Baron for wearing
and dressing his elite units black led
an offensive in Crimea that was halted
by the Red Army for some Wrangell to
flee Crimea to Constantinople using one
of Russia's most famous war songs here
could just be some Soviet set dressing
or the lyrics could hint at these black
clad prisoners about to be halted by a
similar stronger force moving on
okay you may recognize the face of this
Russian officer or maybe you don't
recognize a faceless man Jack in a guard
from Game of Thrones
Tom Alessia if stranger things is
willing to typecast Steve at Harbor as a
russian prisoner from his role in Black
Widow who knows maybe they also have
Russian soldiers who can change their
faces on a ruble and then the camera
crawls up the workers on the railroad
all the live long day I like how the guy
right behind Hopper swings his hammer
but you know the head hits only air and
we see that one of these prisoners is
Jim hopper bald and clean-shaven I love
this because his look
echoes 11 when we first met her back in
season one like L once was hopper is now
a prisoner with more tripping
experiences in this captors likely
appreciate hopper removes his hat wipes
his brow and then that thousand-yard
stare lingers for just a bit too long
that's scary Russian dogs gonna bark
bull good bro Clark it's kind of hard to
do dog in Russian at the same time
though so it feels like that's punching
down a bit
Russian dog says bark ha ha ha they were
being tortured
doesn't look like hopper is looking out
at something in the distance maybe
here's a hunting sound notice the two
guards in the background behind them
they appeared to be standing along some
kind of line in the snow the earlier
aerial shot makes me think it could have
been a fallen tree they do one cut down
for timber for the railroad or did some
other force knock this tree down nearby
rift in a dimension or an escaped
interdimensional monster that we know
was capable of moving trees in Indiana a
break out of some kind of
interdimensional monster could be what
hopper is observing here and if you
listen to audio in the final few seconds
of this teaser we do get a clue
[Applause]
that is the growl of the demagogue in
which we know was in the same facility
that hopper the American was the inept
we're not sure if this is the damaged
organ or just a demo Gorgon but you know
it was implied to the demagogue and was
a solo apex predator and probably wasn't
part of a pack if the Russians have it
in captivity feeding other political
prisoners to it I'm thinking they're
trying to weaponize this beast for
military uses but back to the question
of hopper how is he here there's still a
lot we don't know about the upside down
but the simplest explanation that really
isn't simple at all is that hopper did
not die in the explosion he entered the
rips into the upside down right before
it closed and that the upside down is a
dimension parallel to our own that bends
space in the waste of that secondary
rifts opened by Russians in Siberia
would be relatively close to the Indiana
one hopper just arrived through in
Russian scientists exploring the upside
down from there and have found this man
and wondered why this guy's dressed in a
Russian military uniform let's let's
take him home figure out what's going on
but that explanation would not explain
how they have the Dimmick organ
despite the Dybbuk organs destruction at
the end of season one well perhaps the
answer to this lies in our understanding
of time don't click away a my breakdown
of these season four announcement a
couple months back I pointed out the
clock imagery and if you remember
hoppers a letter to L at the end of
season three referenced reversing time
to turn back to clock it was a
discussion between Steve and Robin about
the logic of the Back to the Future
movie why is it called Back to the
Future
he has to go back to the future because
he's in the past so the future is
actually the present which is his time
perhaps the upside down is a channel
that bends space and time if Hopper went
to the upside down in 1985 he could have
reached in the Russian end of the
wormhole back sometime before 1983 when
the demagogue on was just getting warmed
up this hopper here could be a 1983 or
even well earlier when the USSR was
using prison labor all the time and this
season will show us the origins of how
the demagogue and made its way to
Hawkins Indiana in the first place the
dimma Gorgon could have been a Russian
bioweapon that escaped into the upside
down in the American experimentation
into the upside down in season 1 in the
program L was involved in was the
American attempt to counter that Russian
research but they ended up opening the
door to it wreaking
vaq on barb really and maybe we will see
that the events of the past three
seasons will have been in a wait caused
by hopper this time-travel inversion of
them will go back through everything
like Marty in Back to the Future Part 2
as the attempts to get back home to
Indiana maybe even he'll be presented
with a chance to see his daughter again
hey comment down below with your
theories and for my dark unfiltered
thoughts on this stuff join new
rockstars official discord channel by
becoming a patron BAE at patreon.com
slash new rock stars follow me on
instagram and twitter at EA vasa follow
do rock stars and subscribe to new rock
stars here on YouTube for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]